so back in 2006 when we found it it was
a moment when advertisers really were
beginning to rethink their strategies
you had YouTube still an indie you had
Jack Dorsey sending out his first tweet
and it was also the year when the
blogosphere was just exploding and this
was really scary for brands suddenly you
had this social web emerging which was
fractious and talkative and people were
talking back and it was specific it was
unnerving it was uncharted and to a lot
of brands it felt unruly and that's
where our name comes from you may well
have seen our videos if you've ever seen
any moon walking ponies rollerskating
babies braudy popping chickens and
they're very likely to have come from us
to their viral spread has been powered
by unruly technology and we don't make
the videos we're not video creators we
make the videos famous so since 2006
we've seen massive increases in people
sharing video video has become a social
currency it feeds the water-cooler
moment way back in 2006 dove revolution
was the most shared ad with what we
thought at the time was a massive 60,000
shares fast forward to 2013 dove gained
the most shared out of the year with
dodge real beauty sketches this time
millions of shares over a hundred
million views so how does this happen it
doesn't happen by magic there's a few
myths around video one misses and that
it happens really easily this is the CEO
myth where the CEO says I want a viral
and it shall come to pass so we know for
the most part videos languish they don't
get seen the other methods that it's
unpredictable it's not something you can
plan for we know that's not true either
because we're predicting the share
ability of videos in advance that I'm
really using the data we've been
collecting so first of all it's about
the content we all know content is king
and but more precisely it's about
creating shareable content content that
has a real deep emotional impact on the
audience it's about the intensity of
emotional response and giving people a
reason to share and when I talk about
the intensity of emotional response here
it's about scoring 11 out of 10 it's
about having the hairs on the back of
your neck stand up
and it's that physiological response
that's required to really drive sharing
and then the social motivations is also
key
it's not enough for humans to feel
something very intensely we're almost
compelled it's not it's an our social
DNA to share that feeling on words to
discharge that feeling pass it on
so when you've got your or some content
fantastic you're halfway there then it's
about having a smart distribution
strategy that starts with the player so
the video plays a real campaign catalyst
and lots of people forget this and it
means bringing in an in annotations
invitations to share at various points
in the video the points in the video
when the viewer is most likely to want
to share because they're feeling
incredibly emotionally intense about
what they're seeing once you've got your
player
it's about launching that player
launching the ad into native
environments it's really important to to
spread that content in a way that feels
natural and laces it in the content feed
so that people can see it and it catches
their attention but for brands that are
serious about the video strategy and
want to do it repeatedly in its scale
paid media is the way to guarantee views
so where do we do this to unruly well we
cover off the rest of the web so
something that people don't realize is
it's not just about YouTube when it
comes to video views so just over a
quarter of video views take place on
YouTube that leaves a lot of viewers who
are watching sharing video elsewhere on
what we call yet the open web and the
smart advertisers go beyond YouTube and
think about taking the rest of that
audience they don't want to leave it on
the table and this is a really key
element of our technology because we
have the data on who's doing the sharing
and where they're sharing we can make
sure that we're targeting super sharers
and then programmatically optimizing for
those super shares on day one of a
campaign why is day one so important
it's the most important day because
social diffusion is faster than ever
before so if you look at 2012 22 percent
of shares occur in the first three days
that in itself is phenomenal 2013 we've
seen an almost a doubling of that so 42
percent of shares occurring in the first
three days so think how important it is
to get that video out there trending
everybody watching it and sharing it as
soon as possible to list the viral peak
and then flow that viral decay and this
is a huge opportunity for brands because
they can drive business metrics and well
if someone's watched a video that's been
shared with them what we find is one in
three people go on to talk about that
video one in four people
go on to visit the home page one in five
people search online and almost one in
ten people go on to buy that product so
peer-to-peer recommendation has massive
impact on how we make our buying
decisions and video can be a real
powerful part of that